foreign
comes from Ian in Florida asking for
advice regarding retirement
contributions I'm 27 my wife is 26 she's
a recent stay-at-home mom she has about
35 000 in a Roth IRA I have about 40 000
in a Roth IRA and or in a Roth IRA and
60 000 in a Roth 401k we both max out
our Roth IRAs each year but I also
contribute 10 of my income into
in a Roth 401k at work about 15 total
income going into my retirement accounts
my question is should we be contributing
more in a traditional IRA in her name
and less in my name obviously the
retirement is mostly now going to be in
my name and not hers and I feel somewhat
weird about this even though we are good
Financial Partners what are your
thoughts
uh no I wouldn't feel weird about that
uh if most of it's going into your I
mean as long as you guys are investing
15 of your total income uh I don't
really care where it goes it's just the
importance of putting that money away
for the future so Ian if it leans more
into
your Investments versus hers I mean I'm
fine with that total of 15 of your
household income
should be going at baby step four not
more it sounds like you're doing more it
sounds like you're no it's like there's
a lot of these yeah so like you're doing
15 plus a Roth for your wife it sounds
like if you're going to do a Roth if
you're going to do an IRA for your wife
you can do that as a spousal IRA and
um that's fine and a good mutual funds
and if you've got good 401K Roth and a
match at your place you can do that but
the total of all of this mix should be
no more than 15 Rachel's right you're
concerned about it being in one name or
the other is Irrelevant in the event of
death
you've got a beneficiary on it and it's
her it all goes to her in the event of
divorce the judge is going to take half
of it and give it to her
so there's no I mean there's no downside
for it doesn't matter whose name it's in
because she's protected either way so to
speak you know I've heard people saying
well you should always you know keep
your finances separate and you're fine
you ought to have your own retirement
account handled in case of divorce well
in case of divorce in any state in the
United States they will take half your
freaking 401k and give it to the other
spouse it's part of the deal it's part
of the property settlement okay so you
just you're not there's it's not
protected uh from that so you can't I
can't do that so it won't work all of
our retirement not all but I mean 96 of
my retirement isn't my name because your
mom has been a state-owned mom since
Denise was born 30 some odd years ago
almost 40 years ago now yeah and so
uh you know and consequently I've been
every year but when we do a Roth IRA
over here but I load the 401K in my name
too so when you add it all up it's
mostly in my name but um Sharon's not
the least bit worried
it's a good woman would not occur to her
to be worried about that she assumed she
could take it from me at any time she
wants and she's correct